[Music]
[Applause]
yeah i think we're live and welcome back
to new rocks guys this is the break room
our daily show that keeps you updated on
just what's going on in nerd news uh
coming up today we're gonna be talking
about san diego comic-con here orgasm if
you watch the boys uh madame webb taika
watiti being the ultimate clown and
we're getting into some mcu horror baby
very important enunciation there there's
no mcu horror babies that would be
hirogasm
i think it's okay to be a [ __ ] um
starting off with how who's here today
is
john thompson hi everyone you forgot
your name
i am i'm a [ __ ] baby
cute little heartbeat just a little one
followed by anna
i am your papa bear for the day and my
name plate's over here under phillips oh
yeah
and
anna
molina
hi i'm phillip molina and i've been
trying to reach you about your car's
extended warranty oh my gosh phil
followed by this sweet sweet sweetie
this is benny baby little benny oh he's
sleeping
he's depressed
i know it's been a rough month yeah it's
been a rough month you guys we have the
redemption swear jar as usual with our
super chats i'm looking at camera two i
don't know how tommy feels uh we have
the reverse swear jar so if we reach 100
you know that you guys get to vote on
which one of us gets to swear and curse
up a storm and we're probably just gonna
curse at you because that's what we've
been doing lately and honestly that's
the ammo if we reach 500 dogs we don't
usually tease dogs if we reach 500 dogs
if we reach 500 i'm gonna swear at
philip so aggressively that i'm gonna
try to get myself fired i have not done
a show i have not done a show with you
yet uh really i don't think so i think
we absolutely have that's going to get
you
i try to wipe that every night before i
go to bed you should wipe every night
before you go but uh can i just say i
was just at vidcon for a week
interacting with our lovely fans if i
met any of you there you guys were so
freaking nice and so amazing what is
very funny is the vibes of this show
confuse the hell out of people as to
what i am like where they're like very
much like ready for me to like yell at
them yeah
i'm like you realize that like
i just hate the people i work with yeah
yeah i was crying earlier because of
something you said and now i have to
send it back but i realized we have time
scheduled into our schedule to cry all
together over what philip has said to us
over the course of the day we hold hands
around the picture of philip
the vibe today is so calm and i'm
changing that it's headlights it's
headlights
headlights
marvel's coming to san diego comic con
this year which is uh
blowing everyone's mind clearly because
they haven't been there in three years
feige says we're excited to go and talk
about the future that future better hold
the preview to god dang black panther
too because i'm blowing my mind oh a
scoop uh yes scoob i met someone who's
in black panther too oh okay that
doesn't mean that's not telling us about
well i'm not sure how much i can tell
you but they had like news about how
that movie goes and they have news about
the trailer i should i'll text i'll find
out remember okay this is he's gonna
text no one but he's just trying to get
you to stay here to the end of the show
so i want everybody
to recognize that i get yelled at for
pulling my phone out on this show you
should not be you're not
no you shouldn't be putting out your
phone he's trying to get a school give
me uh texts
excuse me i'm trying to text namor you
can type with your fingers it's a new
show
black panther the next mcu movie coming
out after thor love and thunder do we
think we'll get anything from the
marvels now that uh miss marvel is in
full swing or maybe a secret invasion
tease what do you think we're going to
see
i can't talk sdcc what do you
everyone is scooped
i'm the only one that can speculate
can't we sign ndas do you not sign ndas
i i don't know anything i have nothing
to sign
my contact before the show and i can't
say it right my mom said i
he does this black [ __ ]
we're all afraid
to answer the question very likely right
that would be a great time to release
them i think they're i think they're
because it's so late they're instead of
showing they're going to show the black
panther but they're mainly going to
finally approach the topic of their
halloween special i feel like it's like
the things that they've we've known for
so long but they're not telling us about
period so i feel like it's going to be
very minuscule it will probably show a
lot of what's going to come to disney
plus uh but still good things because
honestly we've been looking at the
disney plush shows more than we've been
looking at the movies recently because
they're giving us all these disney plush
shows yeah and i guess this is big news
because we kind of thought they were
going to skip again this year because
they have d23 coming up in september
disney plus day is the day before uh d23
so i'm excited to get a little bit of
extra news yeah and i don't know you
know it helps our show
that's true uh you're desperate for that
news i am going to be one of these like
people who starts causing the news in
order to scoop it like the jake
gyllenhaal oh yeah oh yeah i hope to be
as problematic as possible
go into the next headline uh real quick
uh uh just i want people to feel wronger
right in the future uh uh sdcc is marvel
going to give us a black panther trailer
or uh halloween uh werewolf by night or
both
no both is too easy pick one and be
wrong everybody
and then when they pick one it's like
and they show both both
yeah if you watch if you watch the boys
hit me on camera too if you watch the
boys herogasm episode the boy star carl
urban billy butcher uh said they ran out
of fake sperm during filming i hate this
heroism
the best episode of the boys to date and
honestly in my opinion and a lot of
people online the best fight scene that
ever was brought to television history
for comet or for superheroes i haven't
seen this yet your mom says not allowed
to watch it my mom loved it my mom
re-watches it to get her feel she also
watched when stormfront got stomped out
over on repeat she downloaded it on her
phone um
it's so good i watched uh jackass
forever the other night and then oh that
one's real sperm and i can't it's burned
into my brain i think i'd be fine with
that
like fake sperm no well it's just like
you're getting you're getting paid i
mean like like you eat every part of the
pig already how about you drink some too
yeah it was a big chunk it was like a
big small like speaking of sprinkles
an american horror story just got added
to the roster for madame webb that
includes now
emma roberts dakota johnson cindy
sweeney celeste o'connor isabelle
mercedes and tahar rahim the
it is stacked and we haven't gotten an
inch ounce a little bit about this dang
movie i'm really excited for this movie
something that was not quite uh
solidified enough news for us to cover
on the show although i'm bringing it up
now is that it seems like kevin feige is
going to be involved as a producer
on these films now deep rumor we can't
confirm it but like that's sort of right
i'm going to text okay
send linda a text um that's sort of you
know what we've been hearing in that
makes me very confident that sony sort
of learned their lesson with morbius and
the venom movies and you know we'll get
a movie closer to no way home i hope
fingers crossed 20
when i was reading the article they were
like following the heat that was venom
carnage they're not even acknowledging
morbius right now they went from venom
carnage to this so it seems like they're
really like not trying to tie a morbius
they're just like let's go from carnage
to this so i think we get more carnage
also because spider-man in this than we
would get more bs can we get um some
super chats uh to just give me i have no
idea what this movie even could be about
so maybe later in the show we can just
read some super chats of what will this
movie be about what is the official
title that they're going or do we know i
don't think i think we'll always have
this madame web story of some sort what
is this madame webb movie going to be
about considering it's not going to have
spider-man in it
that's a good although you know well i
think it's about the intro of her story
because she is also like half dead and
her
oxygen tank thing is like her spider
body so it's probably just her origin
story yeah your spider bodies it's
probably just our origin story uh
through dakota johnson which will be
amazing i think
i like her i've liked her ever since she
canceled ellen yeah honestly that's i
no
no i love her i love her to death uh
taika ytt will star in the upcoming
episodes of mandalorian season three um
he played ig 11 in season one died in
some lava
i'll just play another assassin droid
perhaps what yeah i mean his voice can
be put in anything yeah
that's the funny thing about taika is
that he seems to play like uh cgi
characters more often than he like he's
a little bit of like an andy circus
where you only see andy circus as
a real person partly the joke right is
that like if it's cgi character we're
used to c3po uh anthony
yeah i think so yeah like it's like if
anything they're either neutral or
british right but instead this like kiwi
accent like it's just hilarious
immediately yeah like why is this they
have such a dumb alien from new zealand
i would love for anything for him to be
okay so he was a droid in season one yes
season three he's playing himself and
they're like your voice is familiar and
he's like i do the voice for the truth
what if he is building the droid he's
like a new he's like an anchor person
and they they like call him in to do
voices like that woman whoever seen that
documentary with the woman who is siri
yeah yeah yeah her voice doesn't sound
that much like siri because it's so it's
like
yeah but um you can get her to say some
dirty stuff on cameo
horrible i think i could get some
horrifying big sperm
pig sperm uh ytc put uh the goats
speaking of tiger tt and throw eleven
thunder we have the goats the goat the
goat that is taekwontiti and the goats
and thor love and thunder he put them in
there intentionally to mess with james
gunn according to chris pat uh ytt just
wanted to stick james with some goats
james has to pick up where tycho left
off and he stuck us with some space
ghosts now i don't want to get into
spoilers for where this movie goes
because jessica has seen this film i was
under the impression that they were sort
of going to be with the thor side of
this movie and not with the guardians
that's exactly funny if it's like if
it's the way it plays out is like the
guardians think they're going to be part
of like the huge god butcher oh speaking
of i'm wearing a cool new god british
shirt
like the saving the gods over it's like
actually i really need you to watch
videos you can take parameters
like eating the the with their ship's
name uh the benatar or whatever like
yeah
yeah
i would also love
you know the goats seem to have the
power of the bifrost which is insane to
me um so maybe that's just i mean
obviously the the benatar can get around
and and can teleport too i think right
yeah
yeah the power of the bifrost yeah um we
all have the power of the bifrost um
yeah maybe that's just they they have to
get around via goat and they're just
stuck with these ghosts i like the idea
because kep when i kept reading the
article where they were mentioning like
not normally act directors do this but
the taekwondo can do whatever the hell
he wants so he chooses to do it and it's
like i feel like james gunn could also
do it and give like be like i'm just
gonna put this weird easter egg in there
and now the other director has to find
it and do something with
does anyone here know her in the chat or
in the daschle distance uh
did tyka write thor ragnarok i believe
so i think he did yeah
can we fact check these idiots no i
don't know
no it might be right it's just saying to
me yeah let me text him okay nevermind
uh because the new one he definitely
wrote
uh oh i just gotta i don't know who this
is um
natalie you're calling yourself about
your card
uh no uh because somebody i i didn't
actually get to watch the movie when i
was there the other day when you when
you guys were there i had to leave early
what was that
boom who wrote it daschle in the
distance
eric pearson okay so here's what i heard
okay so uh at least i think you can talk
about this jessica is it fair to say
this movie has ragnarok vibes but a lot
more emotion
yeah yeah
okay thanks
that is why i was so like my thing with
ragnarok i've talked about a lot is that
i think that's a very funny movie that
does not stay with me and i was like i
just wish it was a very funny movie that
had some emotion and then i was thinking
but if tyka wrote it i'm surprised it
didn't turns out he didn't write it but
he did write love and thunder and now
i'm like the guy who did jojo rabbit
right like when he can marry those two
things so now i'm i'm extra pumped for
it thor ragnarok's my favorite movie
really yeah it genuinely i like a movie
that makes me laugh the thing about
marvel movies is we have to study them
you guys we have to watch them on repeat
constantly and it is very fun to watch
them on repeat constantly but you still
get the same just like all dialogue no
fun speech and thor ragnarok gave me
that fun and dialogue every single time
so i can that and it's also not as long
as the other so it's the one i can read
it's my favorite mcu movie is always
like which one can you watch on repeat
and never get tired of and it's still
ragged mine is the office season too
that's the worst season
thor ragnarok is one of those like late
face three movies that feels like a baby
set up to infinity war there were a
couple of those that were like we need
to do a bunch of stuff to get all the
characters in the right places for
infinity war so that we can go do the
infinity saga and this one yeah it kind
of felt like that where they were like
you know well speaking of doing that
right you guys saw this thing about
kevin feige like kind of making it seem
like krazynski is it was just like
almost a gag that he's really weird yeah
you guys really liked uh jungkook
we got a thing about it he's setting you
up so perfectly for it how do you see it
he did but you kind of took it no this
is a different story
i took just okay finish it go ahead and
finish all right did you guys see this
crazy thing kevin feige said jessica
there's teleprompters in this room
i didn't notice that john's been kind of
slow on the prompter so oh my god
oh my god
i didn't see it i heard it because it
was on the dr strange director's
commentary with sam raimi he said uh i'm
taking the story now
he said um he said yeah no kevin was
behind the casting of krazynski and he
thought it was just like kind of cute
because fans really wanted krasinski to
be in the film we've been fantastic
you've seen new rockstars thumbnails for
like past five years putting him in the
in the thumb and he said i don't know
it's an alternate universe so it could
be anyone well yeah it just felt a
little bit like but it's not going to be
him
the way he phrased it felt like we'll
give him this cute little cameo so now
that we'll get to the real stuff and now
that we're here
uh i'm not like kevin john
um
now that kevin feige listens to us who
do we want to fan cast for read
richard's
proper i i legitimately asked him that i
did ask about kevin feige pay any
attention to new rock stars and he made
a funny joke that is actually like i
can't even say because i was like man
you just burned me oh but it was very
funny
it had a little bit of the energy of
thanos and uh
you took everything from me i don't even
know what that was no i don't know
oh no well at least
he loves us
yeah yeah i loved it it was very funny
we got your madame webb answers if you
ever want to uh we'll we'll shout them
out when there's a lull
when there's a little we did get the
pull of what we think we'll see at san
diego comic con and 82 said they thought
it was gonna be black panther two versus
werewolf by night i think we'll see
werewolf by night
it's not big enough to be the only thing
that they talk about obviously but it's
like mudder what if they cover a few oh
that'd be so disappointing i was gonna
text you and see if you wanted to do a
break room live while they were doing
this now we have to do it famous enough
now we have to fill up that's right
that's right i'm not anymore
um
if we do do a live break room on the
saturday that they're having their hall
h panel it'd be very disappointing if we
were just sitting here and we're like
oh okay it's where we'll find out i like
that i like the idea of like like we're
eating like popcorn or something and
watching the live stream maybe maybe
we'll do it if you if you tweet enough
at eric i'm not going on a
jessica won't saturday here monday
through friday it's just like
live from your couch yeah it's me just
laying on my back my ac is off it's hot
i thought you were the thing like from
family go really like your body
[Laughter]
fisher flying through space yeah
this is how bad an athlete i am to me
that is perfect uh no shooting of a
basketball
posture
shoot like an egyptian back here
the beginning of the pandemic i looked
up adult basketball coach nope
oh my gosh oh my god they said no
they're legitimately like they're like
do you have a child with you
i was like no i don't have a job
uh okay now it's time for what
everybody's been talking about in the
chat i noticed before we got started you
guys were asking so much about dr doom
and we're going to get into it marvel
confirmed john krasinski's doctor doom
connection and multiverse of madness the
portal that reed richards enters through
was in fact dr doom's time platform
right there that blue box above his head
was dr doom's time platform michael
waldron was a huge fan and added it as
an homage but like we do on this show
with all our theories
there is mike and how smart michael
waldron is this is now just a domino
effect to what could happen in
potentially in the mcu universe now
knowing that the traveling the time
platform is a time traveling machine
created by dr doom himself uh victor von
doom could be working with reed richards
in a different timeline do you what do
you think
of it well he he always is but do you
think this
victor von doom made the time traveling
platform with reed richards or reed
richards is just like hey can i borrow
this for a second it's gotta be like now
that's starting to make me think that
that's gonna be the plot it's gonna be a
time travel plot for them maybe it's why
you know we we love we always talk about
the idea of setting it in the 1960s yeah
but it's like maybe they've done it
maybe they skipped all the way to the
year 3000 or whatever he meets his like
you know future future future progeny uh
and then on the way back maybe uh doom
stayed behind and then maybe it
continued to age or something and became
like a dictator or something that's an
alternate timeline that it returns to
it's uh
back to the future too yeah right we
gotta go back it's about your future
kids that'd be so fun if they played
along those lines of just like and
doctor was like okay and then he go he
just turns bad at the end yeah i also
love there's like a graveyard of old
rogue theory episodes where like how are
we gonna get the fantastic four and the
x-men into the mcu and the answer is as
simple as like well they're time lords
and also can travel inter-dimensionally
so we're gonna do that one that's very
easy yeah
there's i talked about later in this but
the fantastic four did use they took the
time traveling platform once and went
back to the time where king the
conqueror was rama tut and like in a
dramatic persona and like confronted him
and so there's
this is already attached it's already
written in the stars this time traveling
platform to go into the mcu so do you
think that uh the fantastic four we
could see later on going back to the
ramat that we saw on moonlight not only
do i think that i think that might be
the plot of a future ride at avengers
campus oh that's okay i would get on
that
i love that mummy ride at uh yeah
like right like they put across
the wrong theme park but yeah but it's
yeah they're like we need you to help us
go through time and stop doctor doom
let's go and then ant-man's there for
some reason sure yeah ant-man's nervous
he's narrating the whole thing
my favorite idea for this is that reed
is a huge dick in that universe and took
it from dr doom his teammate dr doom is
in love with susan storm and they were
like supposed to be and he's just
it's like the snape it's like harry
potter's dad and harry potter it's like
snape was actually the good guy in snape
and the dad was like a douchebag i want
that to be the case for the fantastic
four deniers i also wonder right like we
we
dr doom kind of has to be in the
upcoming fantastic four movie yeah
it's going to be really disappointing do
we think
it'll be
you know he'll be the main villain or do
you think they'll just kind of set him
up to be a recurring villain like loki
or even thanos or whatever
oh okay yeah well yes i need him and i
know someone in the chat was like they
ruined dr doom in the first movie don't
ever do it again i need them to touch it
again doctor doom is in so many comics
the previous one with miles tell him
yeah oh yeah they um honestly did
everybody dirty in that movie either way
i needed did anybody come out that movie
looking good i didn't mind it i truly
like jordan kind of always comes always
comes out
comes out every time but i dr doom is
such a huge character for me and in the
comics and just having him in secret
wars is so big i thought we were selling
camera two is so big that i think we
need to see him again and get that set
up and started going get the ball
rolling for like secret war so so kanga
conquer probably the big bad or
incursions maybe we think of phase four
maybe even phase five i guess i guess
we're personal like kang is like a
character that we care about because he
has not a mission right do we think that
doom
even further down the line do we have to
wait for another 20 years until we get
doomed as like this overarching we gotta
wait until we get fantastic but you
can't get doomed by himself you have to
get fantastic four five sure we do care
about him if we go the nathaniel
richards route right right like every
right where it's like like king so
what's the actor's name again jonathan
uh uh michael b good jonathan i see what
you're doing with black men actors
you're putting b in their middle name
if he is a character that we introduce
as a villain whatever but then he's also
like the character that we need their
help that's that terminator 2 angle
right where it's like
right this is for kang but it's the same
actor he's kind of playing a different
role and if we can trust you and he's
like you're my my ancient uh relative
and like you look pretty different from
us too like and the version that we've
heard about that looks exactly like you
kind of was like manipulating playing us
all as puppets that is a way where i
feel like we could be on this journey
with kang care about this character
and
basically i'm saying
i disagree jessica for a moment ago
which said we wouldn't care
no i know all right okay
i was wondering but um i see why you
would care it's more so that we just
haven't been set up yet to care about
kane yeah you don't know who he is
really we just know that he has a
million of himself and he's egotistical
i kind of thought king came out looking
better than sylvie did at the end of
loki or he who remains
yeah i'm kind of keeping your [ __ ]
together right now it was like daschle
right now right yeah thank you
um okay reed richards and nathaniel
richards obviously nathaniel richards is
like the great great great great great
great great great grandson of reed
richards in the comics do you think
we'll still have a family tie between
those two characters yes you that's the
what makes it interesting okay
but you don't think it'll be you don't
think it'll be like
all right that's not what you were just
saying i wasn't paying attention i can't
wait till you guys go to your meeting
where you cry about how yeah yeah yeah
just because i i wasn't paying good
enough for our next topic anna's gonna
walk us through our madame webb uh plot
ideas here uh let's hear them out and
judge our audience okay
absolutely if i am a number one fan and
expert of star wars i am a number two
fan and expert of madame webb
what am i going through right there
you're killing me for not going over
there yeah perfect so uh oh today i have
my contacts in so i can actually kind of
read those well kind of something voice
says madame webb is going to be a
fantasia like musical featuring pretty
people weaving
like a basket weaving pewdiep pretty
people together i think it is what does
that mean
that sounds gorgeous i'll watch it i'll
watch it for that twenty dollars it cost
to see a movie in l.a uh theodore harris
what's up bud says beginning of the
live-action spider-verse i like this i
like this right she she does some
spider-verse stuff in the comics oh gosh
i'm showing that i'm also the number two
but lord and miller are doing this
live-action silk series um that is gonna
be tied into sort of the across the
spider-verse stuff so there's some
precedent for sony to be doing across
the spider-verse live-action
stuff is there no way home already is
set up for the spider-verse live-action
i think we just don't know where marvel
and and and sony are when it comes to
the spider-verse right right yeah yeah
we have
more oh oh oh oh oh oh these aren't okay
well fray girl says madame webb is about
a madam whose kink is wrapping people in
webs and watches them freak out and then
she charges them five thousand dollars
really
kind of like that you guys ever see that
movie i think one's called hard candy oh
yeah another one is um promising young
woman at that same time okay yeah young
promising woman promising young woman uh
michael b
promising
uh
both of those are about like playing
that angle of like punishing men but you
come off as a victim so madame webb is
playing the role of the fly caught in
the web but actually like as a spider
comes in she's attracting a spider-man
or a venom type whatever she's actually
the threat that'd be very funny i'm more
upset you didn't make a jameson giant
peach reference how would i make that
right because she got a giant because
there's just a spider in it so
charlotte's web reference yeah i would
have loved that too i love spiders
and then we have some more super chats
but they don't have to do with madame
webb so they're gonna answer them dead
to us for right now or we'll come back
to them later oh my god
can we get that swear please can we get
that swear swear please can we swim
swear please
okay we want to thank athletic greens
for sponsoring the break room today
we've been we've been taking a g1 from
athletic greens to help boost our
immunity and give us energy throughout
the day with one with one delicious
scoop of ag-1 you're absorbing 75 high
quality vitamins minerals whole foods
source superfoods probiotics and
adaptogens to help you start your day
right the special blend of ingredients
supports your gut health your your
nervous system your immune system your
energy your recovery your focus
and your aging ag-1 is a lifestyle
friendly is lifestyle friendly whether
you eat keto paleo vegan dairy free or
gluten-free it supports better sleep
quality and recovery mental clarity and
alertness it's cheaper than
i love when we have philip on athletic
green stays just for this next sentence
it's cheaper than getting all of your
different supplements yourself because
i'm the only person you know that
actually
does weight you've got your awesome i
love it i love it
it scares me i don't know how your
throat isn't just like packed crammed to
the gills with pills every day i'm very
impressive at this point of
what i can swallow okay okay uh it's
it's cheaper than getting all your
different supplements yourself and
you're investing in an all-in-one
nutritional insurance and for every
purchase
we donate to
athletic greens donates to organizations
helping to get nutritious foods to kids
in need including no kid hungry here in
the united states
if you're a frequent breaker uh you
might know that i was out sick last week
not covid related thankfully but i was
out um
i snuck some athletic greens home with
me check it out they also have
little pocket-sized ones and it was like
between you know cheeks dying yeah
between my cheeks dying in bed i would
just like pound in athletic greens and
it would just give me that like little
bit of sick energy to like go do a thing
for an hour and then you know i could go
back to like uh whole foods has a
wellness job yeah totally like when you
need to like quickly pretend that you're
uh you're a functioning person yeah
absolutely i just quick check a pig
sperm continue
well this is a lot a lot more legal and
a lot less expensive vitamins you need
vitamin c
um right now it is time to reclaim your
health and arm your immune system with
convenient daily nutrition it's just one
scoop in a cup of water every day that's
it no need for a million different pills
and supplements to look at gesture for
your help to make it easy athletic
greens is going to give you a free
one-year supply of immune supporting
vitamin d i had the bag but it fell over
and five free travel packs with your
first purchase all you have to do is
visit athleticgreens.com break room
again that's athleticgreens.com
break room to take ownership over your
health and pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional insurance here's a promise
i'll make to you okay to never lie to
you oh no okay
but also i will i do have a countertop
with an insanely stupid amount oh yeah
get us a pick so we can make fun of it i
can and like if some people out there
might be
i have like they're for different
purposes like the bundles like this
bundle has a certain effect on the human
body and this bundle has a certain
effect on somebody else's human body
whatever uh but i can show it to you all
i will compare the ingredients and see i
might fully convert
if it one scoop in my you know i drink
that gallon of water every day that one
scoop would actually save me a bunch of
money if it has as much i'll do a
legitimate comparison i won't lie to you
guys about whether or not i switched to
it but i will check to see if i switched
i will say i also just been sipping on
this throughout the break room it's like
a very simple drink which i like it's
not one of those healthy drinks that you
just have to like fully slam and get it
over with it's like yeah just yeah like
the big spring i'm not going to give up
my vita gummies because i like the way
they taste it's a good start to my day
but i'll drink the i'll drink it with
them go to the flooded greens.com
breakfast
just start inviting gummy all the greens
what are you waiting for okay i am not
going to this hell yeah but some of the
people at this table are new access is
going to rtx this weekend skyler's going
to rtx new rockstars yes skyler our
camera person off to the side is going
to be on rtx new rockstars is going to
be uh appearing live in austin texas as
part of the rtx austin 2022 podcast
festival that is happening july 1st
through july 3rd jessica clemons will be
there philip molina will be there eric
voss will be there thomas michael
bechtold will be told tommy b jordan
told uh we'll be there so if you've ever
wanted to see some of your favorite new
rockstars people in person now's your
chance and the really cool thing is to
save a little bit of money on your
ticket they're going fast click the link
in the description and use our promo
code new rockstars all one word and um
it'll give you a little bit of a
discount and that way we can see you
there and it'll be super fun i'm gonna
be in austin really early helping set
some of this up if you guys have any
anybody in austin are really really
familiar with austin you can tweet at me
but also during the chat too what should
what else should i do in austin what
else should the rockstars team do in
austin while we're there well oh yeah i
was born in austin so if any of you know
what could be done in austin you weren't
born i hope you get so many tweets
there's a great maternity ward at a
hospital in austin
it's time for mandatory fun
i've been talking a lot
um so i'm gonna leave
the graphics i'm gonna leave and someone
else is gonna come in and replace me
okay
well
while he's gone
hi
uh
i am uh unfortunately unfortunately i'm
i'm
c costa uh yeah that's my name
i i i usually have three people in my
line of work usually have three names i
only have two um
unfortunately team michael bechtold was
supposed to be here today but he
couldn't make it um for obvious reasons
so he sent me his intern to be here yeah
he drowned in sperm he sent me his
intern to be here instead i'm a little
bit more level-headed but still
ruthless she's not feeling it
over it already
oh no you may you may should i leave no
okay um
there's a story in the news
i'm dropping the bit i can't commit i
can't commit with jessica mad at me um
this the the teleprompter um
what does that say
oh baby
can you read that
anna
i don't have my glasses play my graphic
times three
is that what else is yeah
great job times three i was trying to
set jessica up she doesn't have her
glasses on um tommy is away this week
and requests that we reach out to
michael bechdel for these pictures oh my
god he's dead we're going through it
again his goose heart didn't react
kindly to his tiger blood
so there's a story
this is very cute
there's a story this week we got it from
jessica's gonna break
we got it again from the doctor stranger
the multiverse of madness um audio
commentary michael waldron was talking
about how the original ending to
multiverse of madness had
strange supreme and doctor strange from
earth 616
swap and they were going to have doctor
strange
616 stuck in the incursion universe
and it was going to be strange supreme
who ended up making it out with america
chavez
and pretending and then the third eye
opening
in the post-credits scene was going to
be a nod to the fact that it was strange
supreme being the one who
made more sense
well i think they were saying like if
you read the uh dark cold and you don't
have the powers of the scarlet witch
then you go insane or whatever it is but
that's a very scary and like messed up
dark way to end that film
right and so we it got us thinking um
also this wasn't the story we were doing
for this and that's my fault um
uh that got us thinking
what what other characters we don't have
a lot of horror in the mcu we did get
some in multiverse and madness we maybe
got a little bit of wanda vision i want
to know from you guys what mcu
characters would you put into a horror
movie franchise
franchise yeah well that's got harder i
don't know you think so
i mean if it's a one obvious
like the shining you would say like i
want to put this character in the
shining universe even though that's a
one-off film i guess we did get dr sleep
but i won't count that well you could
just right off the bat you could put
tony stark wanda oh there's so many uh
shanxi
a lot of characters in the orphan
universe oh that's funny
oh because their parents are dead get
batman in there just for fun
i said oh because they're chill they're
they're childless parents i feel like
you could make an entire horror movie
out of that one scene in multiverse of
venice where they're going through all
the different universes and in one their
faces split apart into chunks that that
yeah just the cube the cube world that
they're in i didn't want to explore any
more of that but if they made a whole
movie out of it i'd go see it yeah
that's it's really difficult to drink
pig semen in that universe it's hard to
sneak pig semen into the movie theater
let me tell you what sometimes you just
gotta let it absorb into the do you have
any answers
well i'm trying really hard to think i'm
like dog and it's sleepy
it's the most distracting thing you
could have brought he's asleep phillip
said before this episode that this is a
really casual show and i do feel very i
feel very casual today oh that's good
i've got my leg
do you have an answer um no i'm waiting
for phillips okay okay i'm just coming
up with this now it's uh
what if what's the movie where the
little girl's head gets knocked off
hereditary hereditary oh no in
hereditary it's a hereditary hereditary
sequel series that's somewhere where you
put um
baron mordo
and uh or or any of these these witches
and like like obviously scarlet witch or
whatever and all these characters and
they just like expand that they take the
that whole hereditary thing of trying to
what are they they're almost trying to
do like the omen kind of thing with the
little kid like yeah one of them they
expand that to be like worldwide right
like they use an amplifier of that that
whole thing
uh it's just real creepy the other thing
i was thinking was like there's
something there with candyman
and um and isaiah
thomas bradley isaiah bradley right uh
of like what if like one of his stories
when he was a super soldier like back in
like 1965
was you know in dealing with like racism
in the south and a candy man style
villain
i think what i want to see is
uh a show come out on hulu
and
we no one really knows what it is kind
of like a weird drop and you're watching
it and it's like a new entry into the
paranormal activity franchise
and you see
like this this like sort of prototypical
american family sort of get you know
haunted by this mysterious being and
then that's what leads us into one
division
season two is like her second attempt of
like going into a new multiverse and
trying to like impose herself on a new
family and it's just like way more
horror movie and way more intense and
then she ends up murdering this entire
family and reanimating their corpses to
like
someone and wise t gold ttv said put
bucky in pan's labyrinth and
honestly do you imagine a sleeper agent
waking up in pan's labyrinth he would go
insane would he even win would he
i don't think bucky would win that would
be kind of like um the
aliens right or or the third alien movie
where like it's military-trained people
having to deal with monsters yeah so
there would be a really interesting
version like how does bucky handle pants
labyrinth
or pan it's tough because usually in
horror movies i feel like it centers
around the victim right and all of the
people in the mcu have like super powers
or things that make them sort of like oh
that's why i was trying to think of like
okay so who could be a villain that has
super powers too so that's what i was
going with the candyman thing too but
what was your your one again real quick
one division season two
maybe you think of what's the netflix
show actually the haunting one oh of
hill house or whatever
yeah
you could do a wanda based version yeah
that's what she's like um she's it's
like the kids like billy and tom tommy
they're seeing their other mother yeah
reflections and stuff oh you know what
another mother is now
now i know what it is now i know what
other mother is you know do you know
that i threw a party where i had this
weekend
put her up on stilts and like had her
like do like a crazy spider thing while
i hate that and then i took a picture
and kissed her on this on the still on
the side which legs
uh i can't think of one these are all
everyone in the chat has much better
than the ones i've lost
and i'm just trying to think of one that
could do justice and i can't you guys
are much better you guys have been
saying punisher a lot which is
interesting very interesting punishers
are good for like an actual realistic
horror movie versus like though i could
see punishment doing jeepers creepers
right because like that that scene and
jeepers creepers of the police station
yeah
this person was saying put jeepers
creepers into the mcu i think it's
easier and fun to come up with a
character a horror character that should
be in the mcu because jeepers creepers
would be my number one pick for a super
a horror person to be in the mcu and
then maybe like
not leatherface leatherface doesn't
doesn't work for the mcu
but the rest are good tyrell taylor
cheated said deadpool versus the marvel
zombies that's right there we're putting
them into non-mcu properties but i do
want to see a lot more with marvel
zombies and we're we are getting like
werewolf by night or getting blade which
could kind of dip into horror a little
bit i don't want to just eat more
marbles no
otto says read oh
just kidding
oh
should i hide the user on this channel
i'm giving you your moment otto said
reed richards in the saw movie and that
made me think like with all those
abilities that some of the mutants have
you could get some gruesome new like
torture
like with the stretchy arms i mean wanda
was a very good um
[Music]
what was the guy's name what's his name
uh spaghetti
jigsaw thank you she was a good chick
yes spaghetti hands
i love edward spaghetti hands as one of
my favorite horror movies
how about predator predator would be
amazing in the mcu yeah predator would
actually genuinely be tops
predator with the guardians oh as we'll
say predator versus the x-men um because
predator would be a mutant but like
would kill all the mutants are you guys
excited for prey that predator prequel
movie that's coming out yeah
maybe okay that's my fault i have my
quarrels with what excited for it
i just don't want them speaking english
oh there's gonna be there's gonna be a
version where you can uh they're gonna
put out a uh dubbed version maybe where
they're not speaking english they're
speaking so they think about subtitles
yeah or use or use context clues and
it's just another language i hate the
idea if they're doing english so now i'm
not into you were like i wasn't excited
what i was thinking is there is for
those of you that don't know the alien
and predator universe has those like
those links and it's very interesting
once you get into that that like
predators are super ultra trained
warriors and aliens are like the almost
the most difficult thing to kill and
like and like hunt and so like that's
their relationship so the history of the
super alter trained warriors is
certainly interesting you just farted
yeah i just farted out in through my
mouth uh craving the hunter
in a predator alien right now trying to
collect yeah yeah
craven the hunter
stealing
realizing the greatest game is killing
humans and then stealing the skin of
humans is a true horror film oh god that
is and that's what i qualified because
someone else said wanda's kids wesley
said want his kids in the final
destination
destination where she keeps getting a
clip of her kids on a dang roller
coaster and is like no
just like just watching choices
i love the final destination i would not
mind that kind of a concept yeah i can't
drive on the freeway with those
logs without thing is going to fall
apart and go through my canning booths
elevators
oh the elevator yeah oh
the conversation came out in like 2001
the first one the first one is actually
gruesome the other ones are very fun we
hit a hundred we hit it thank you kevin
shafer for putting us over the edge
right now thank you thank you we'll see
make it a goodie um i would absolutely
love a final destination or like what
maybe maybe with the multiverse theory
everything that went wrong like all the
times that a certain character died in a
different universe in a horrific way
i love that i would
that's
love
i
idea a series where it was like oh
if thanos it's like a what if series but
if everyone had died and it's like yeah
that'd be so fun i think i just solved
it okay it's doctor strange
dreamwalking and being hunted by freddy
krueger through those drinks that's
pretty good you think he wouldn't be
hiding freddy krueger
uh
i feel like they're both chasing they're
just drinking
and then they catch each other and
they're like you me me you yeah
hey jessica
you get
[Music]
oh i think we're choosing people in the
chat people in the chat like you when i
go off on them who wants me to curse
them out in the chat go off um i'll
choose i'll blindly i'll close my eyes
and i will go beep beep beep beep beep
beep beep and i'll choose which one
we'll know in about two minutes that
delay is real
i mean i think that's what mr guy is
asking for
why are you guys liking when i yell at
you seems like i don't know it made me
feel weird last time you did like i
wasn't proud of my reaction
it was like i hadn't seen you do that
and i was like whoa i like i technically
have some people's bosses here but that
day you were my boss yeah that was
impressive
one of the mounds of pills you took that
day was from a different sponsor
oh god um i'll i'll cuss you out uh mr
krabs sorry mr krabs
look here you got me a camera for him
you're a piece of [ __ ]
garbage man
so are you wesley sorry you awesomeness
if i could
like i said before get that leash off my
back stand i put it around your neck and
i'll drag you through my house you will
eat the slop that falls to the floor you
eat the trash that i don't even want to
throw in the trash this is a compost you
are a maggot to me nothing but garbage
and i will never ever respect you in my
days
this is how i know philip and i are
different because that made me
uncomfortable in a different way i got
it
very sad and they're multiplying
and they're multiplying in greece you
guys i don't even know if we have time
to do our last segment unfortunately
let's let's give it to him oh i'll do a
really quick uh this clip show store uh
this clip i'm releasing
this uh this time for the breakman
breakdown play my graphic baby
i like this one it's cute eat after your
source
this is a break from breakdown of
eric voss our baby daddy uh
my baby daddy um just rolled in with a
new break room or with a new breakdown
about the thor and guardians looking
over the map of territories and thor
love and thunder let's go play that clip
another new shot shows thor with the
guardians on their ship the benetar
reviewing a star map holo display
showing disaster calls of which there
are 1567
and counting clearly gore has been
getting busy the display shows the star
map is a 3d concentric map organized
into these jigsaw sectors which i find
interesting because they could be the
political boundaries of the galaxy one
sector for the cree territory one sector
for the xandarian territory etc etc
battle lines and maps that could be
redrawn as the marvel's explores a war
between the cree and the skrull and a
cree invasion of earth
good points
i love eric saying i'm also going to
talk to you guys in the chat i see a lot
of you in the chat being like when are
they going to talk about dr doom we
actually talked about doctor doom at the
beginning of our episode where we cover
in our discussion um so you can scroll
back i guess or you can wait until it
comes out later but we do have a really
good in-depth doctor doom discussion
about how we are going to see doctor
doom in the mcu and i stand by it but
either way eric vos's theory i don't
think it's too far off and i think a lot
of time on the break room breakdown i'm
constantly like i disagree but i don't
disagree i think these are easily going
to be the territories that we're going
to see in the marvels going up to uh
secret invasion
do you guys agree that we're gonna this
is a possibility for this crease world
war
well the thing that he's saying where it
already happened on earth
that thing oh no no no no uh that that
is a point that i wanted to bring into
this conversation which is to say like
we saw the bengal in miss marvel
um was on a severed cree arm and right
the question is like okay we're gonna
get this cree scroll war do we think
that this is like world war ii for the
cree and the scroll and we already had a
pre-scroll war on earth and that's why
this arm is severed right in that way
and that will sort of lay the groundwork
for i like that as a certainly if that's
the way they're going because it does do
that thing of like
there's
in in in every like universe based uh ip
for some reason it's like and that
happened on earth and it's like why is
it so damn special and it's like maybe
it wasn't that special it just happened
to be this barren wasteland that
happened to host the grease called war
but yeah having hosted that war now it
makes sense since there's weird terrigen
mist floating around and this meteor
that came and gave us the heart-shaped
herb and all that kind of stuff you grow
up under power lines right you're going
to be interesting right
no that's a really good point we've all
seen more in the world
it's like anime they're always like an
anime people always get hit by a bus and
come too as like a superhero or like uh
some sort of demon is just like hey
you're my earth god got hit by a bus but
i do like this idea right we know that
there are people in the mcu that are
already keeping an eye on this so it
would make sense that these characters
are sort of aware of cree and school
scroll boundaries we got that line from
far from home where nick fury said
something along the lines of i thought
cree sleeper cells was confidential
information or whatever he said so like
there are people on earth that know and
i mean obviously that was talos in that
movie so
as a scroll he might know more about
that kind of thing but there are people
with this information kicking around and
marvel does like to sort of lay
groundwork before we're about to jump
into something major next year with
secret invasion and the marvels so this
would make a lot of sense to me i don't
know do you have her permission feige
yeah thank you for thank you for
checking in with us yeah anyway it's
always very kind somebody asked us i'm
gonna go uh if we're ever gonna do an
all-female break room have we done
enough didn't we do an all-female
episode i don't think so no let's get it
on yes i don't know
we talked about it but it's we got
scheduled wait hold on we
you have three
all minutes we're gonna answer the super
chats with the three-legged dog i don't
what you put it oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my god
this is why we don't do it on female
episodes
the dogs hate us
we are running out of time should we go
through some of these super chats real
fast christy says moon night season two
would be a great thing for san diego
comic-con or maybe a feature film uh or
an entire moon night universe we know
chrissy loves egypt she's always in for
a little egyptology um yoshi wants uh
x-men to be introduced at san diego
comic-con eugene johnson says neymar do
we can we check in with our source did
we send that text and we did send it
back someone in the chat just said
trauma
for both of us
she can't hurt you now
oh no oh no wait this dog had four
it
legs
the animal has spoken umbrella academy
please i see you in the chat i see you i
hear you and i also saw someone i'll
bring it up again you know that's how
you women this is how you get your this
is how you get stuff done in a male
dominated world
i'm going to talk about umbrella academy
and get out of here this is a women's
camera i'm going to talk about umbrella
academy and i'm going to talk about
hurricane until they let me do a video
on umbrella academy and arcade we talked
about that without you today
you were unavailable um
can we get a suit there was a super chat
with someone bennett in his name he had
a really lovely message okay
okay here we go david david henry
bennett do you want to read it can you
read it from there oh there's a big
tripod blocking my window hey go for it
john okay hey y'all i just want to say
that you all light up my day very nice
and make me feel great i used to talk
about marvel and theories all the time
with y'all oh all the time and with
y'all i feel like i have a home thank
you so much that's why we do this that's
why we do this because a lot of us also
didn't have that and then we all got
together and decided we were going to
talk about it did we get a second cursor
oh we did
we swear to god
jessica do you want to swear at
well we should we should also like wrap
it up
honestly let's just each get one just
pass it around real quick the swear
stick password i'm glad you took that
[ __ ] dog's leg off
i'm upset that um
you're gonna [ __ ] that dog's leg out
later
even though you ate it um i'm really
[ __ ] sorry about that dog thing i
promise i didn't do anything to
yeah that's a shakespearean one he
invented the word submarine and queef
i can't get over good for him
i can't get over that dog
thank you so much for queefing with us
on the break room today we hope you
drink an entire gallon of pig sperm
we'll see you tomorrow and for the rest
of the week we're off on friday because
we're going to be at rtx but come and
say hi to us while we're there and you
know obviously come with us on the break
room tuesday and wednesday and thursday
we'll see you tomorrow
yay bye